hazel und der joker und timmy und joe
and influencers projekt
[Musik]
si
das trifft uns
wieso wir sie mal unbedingt den mund
aufmachen wenn man jetzt einfach nur
diese creepy bilder von dieser rolle
sieht denkt man sich auch nur sowas
vielleicht hat sie ja ein paar tolle der
ems bekommen ist die single weiß ich
nicht naja hashtag für mehr wären die
täter instagram sie sind gerade aus dass
jetzt die kritische wird und sie sich
darüber dass keiner gehört hat soll
videos mir ein bisschen zugriff muss ich
sagen
die idee dahinter ist cool haben die
sich ein bisschen mühe gegeben auf jeden
fall
und jetzt steht er ganz knapp
damit wir sicherstellen können dass du
nicht infiziert wird schauspielerisch
muss ich sagen irgendwie wo das für mich
zu viel gestreckt in den blöcken die
lustigkeit aus diesem video obwohl es
auch nicht lustig ist
ich will doch gar nicht wird daran sie
nächstes mal könnt ihr euch gerne
jemanden engagieren der es gelernt hat
drehbücher zu schreiben oder es halt
einfach gut kann man muss es ja nicht
lernen man muss es nur gut können
[Musik]
ich habe schon wieder nicht lesen können
die grünen machen mir das zu schnell
alles okay warte 11 prozent der
15-jährigen können nicht richtig lesen
und schreiben
[Musik]
6 millionen gegenüber den überbelegten
wohnungen über becken über welten
das problem ist man muss die zuschauer
auch ein bisschen zeit lassen und um zu
lesen und das war einfach viel zu viel
auf einmal geballert und gebt euch doch
ein bisschen mehr zeit und diese scheiß
texte einzubinden wenn ihr unbedingt
solche langen texte einbinden wollt so
versteht es kein mensch und welches ist
juden heute ich habe raphael reiß und
harte nuss und vanille mit erdbeeren
kann es nur empfehlen
ja das teil ganz ganz unangenehmen kann
es unangenehm
also geht so berichteten bounty versuche
das so ist niemand interessiert sich für
eis das ist so wenn politiker innen
nutzern machen
ich habe auf youtube gesehen dass es
heute gibt die warm essen reden und ganz
viele views absterben also ich und das
machen wir mal heute nach seit auch
diese sache bei so formaten wo man essen
und gleichzeitig irgendwie reden soll es
geht halt nicht entweder du isst
produkte rede
was ich nicht aber storage muss der bz
roger ist noch kein angebot keine
krawatte mehr als das hat einfach ein
drei jahre altes bild nebenan aktuell
bild und was jetzt zur toll daran
ich habe einen minibus sie halte
obstkiste ausgelegt und da kommen wir
zur heute meine selbst gezwungen gucken
2 helga ist mutterpflanzen und video wo
ich mit meinen fans zusammen meinen
gucken in meinen mini hochbeet
einpflanzen
die person muss gerade film denkt sich
so scheiße was mache ich hier
sie kommen gerade pflanzen beim wachsen
zu um ganz ganz toll für dich aber das
hättest du auch wirklich nicht auf
instagram post müssen also ich verstehe
noch nicht so ganz ob er ist ironisch
meint und sich selbst auf den arm nimmt
und einfach so super locker ist wirklich
nur das thema ja meint es ist einfach zu
folgen das hat bis jetzt noch kein
anderer politiker oder politikerinnen
geschafft hat schon 2,2 millionen
ich kann das definitiv verstehen warum
thomas sattelberger so viele follower
wird
ja okay jetzt ihr gewebe warum es so
wichtig ist gehen zu gehen am wechsel
zunächst die bundestagswahl geht dahin
eier und wir entscheiden werden die
markt kommt also wer wäre wer wäre geht
sagt man oder nicht und vielleicht
vergesse ich nicht diesen platz
abonniert